[Music]
you are listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum very special guest in
the show I'm a huge Fright Night fan
Ryan is sitting in front of my Fright
Night poster signed by Tom Holland who's
also coming on the podcast to talk about
horror but today we have a great guest
I mean you know him from Fright Night
I mean being married to Susan Sarandon
wants as well among other things that's
true princess bride uh I mean look he's
done so much work I mean he was
nominated for an Oscar we're gonna get
that we're going to get into all that
Chris Sarandon is here but don't go just
yet don't don't fast forward just yet uh
Ryan you have a good week I did uh I did
I did a comedy roast over the weekend
first how was that someone's birthday he
wanted to get roasted for his birthday
did you roast him good I did and then he
had to roast everyone else on the panel
it was fun I had to do a little roast
song did someone roast you oh I got
roasted you got hurt oh hammered oh yeah
in ways I didn't think possible oh
really and also in ways I thought
possible do you get upset when people
roast you uh no I mean this it's all in
the good spirit of it I mean I I got
everyone uh everyone else got me uh I
think a good one was I look like
uh someone tried to draw Walter Jr from
Breaking Bad from scratch I could see
that yeah but they said Walter Jr they
look like a Russian Walter Jr I could
see that that's amazing I've heard that
a lot before that's amazing I can
totally see that I never thought that
until just now uh I was at uh James
Gunn's wedding jam and uh James Gunn and
Jennifer Holland they got married and uh
I was one of the people who introduced
them and it was a lot it was the best
wedding I've ever been to in my life
I've never seen such a beautiful wedding
ever and great people there I knew many
of the people that were there so it was
really nice and uh you know Jan got up
at the end and gave a uh beautiful
heartfelt speech everybody was in tears
just beautiful and uh she said and thank
you to Sarah Sanderson and to Michael
Rosenbaum for introducing us but when
they meant she said my name all the guys
from the bachelor party just went
it was just everybody looked at me and I
was like what stuff it was like well
Rose and Mom you're the first person to
ever get booed at a wedding
but uh it was it was a treat um I don't
do great with altitude but I uh survived
it and uh it was glorious I just went
and visited my grandmother she's 94. she
lives in a assisted living home sort of
an assistant it's really nice actually
and she likes it which is most important
but you know at the end when they
dropped me off at the hotel
it was last night and uh
she just touched my face and she just
said my boy my boy
I love you so much Michael don't ever
forget that it was just like one of
those moments where I'm like is this the
last time I'm gonna see her I hope not
but I know that time is coming so it
made me think just tell people you love
them just be present be it's like again
being in the moment not waiting till
it's too late of course my grandmother
would have known I loved her anyway
but uh meant today I just got off a
plane so I'm a little out of it took a
little nap was with Blanche she just
brightens my day you know it's so weird
I'm like a parent
because parents show their oh look at my
child isn't he the cutest I constantly
Now show pictures of Blanche my not my
grandma my Blanche my dog and people are
I'm like they're like oh great I mean I
constantly do it is that weird yeah it
is weird
but like it will you treat your dog like
a child know that I'd show everyone
pictures of my dog constantly I mean
that's kind of the same thing but I mean
but she's a cute pup I don't blame you
she is she's an angel hug the ones
dearest to you folks uh I've been
meditating I hope you've been taking
care of yourself Ryan you've been going
to therapy still yep that are helping
great I like that uh and I obviously no
better helps a sponsor and they're
awesome they've been with me I want to
just take a second to say thank you
better help thank you for being the
sponsor and staying with us and I think
a lot of times we talk about mental
health and our well-being and it better
helps just perfect fit and I think
that's why they stick around and that's
why uh
it just it works it's a nice
relationship so thank you our socials
please follow us and write a review if
you like the podcast it helps
substantially our handles are at inside
of you podcast on Facebook and Instagram
at inside you pod on the Twitter we look
forward to reading your review and
hopefully you'll follow us and see what
we're up to uh if you want any merch go
to the inside of you online store we got
great new stuff and great new stuff
coming autograph scripts lunch boxes
from Smallville that they're selling out
you got to get this Smallville lunch box
they're pretty badass tumblers other
great stuff uh inside of you online
store and if you want to become a patron
the patrons really save this show they
also save talkville they're really you
guys without you I've told you this
before I just talked to the patrons on
YouTube live we do that every month and
I always thank them but I hope they know
that I'm sincere go to patreon.com
inside of you to support the podcast
there's different tiers different things
that I send to you personal notes yada
yada yada thank you guys and also I'll
be in San Francisco Columbus and
Pittsburgh at the end of November and
into December so uh try to come see me
and I'm also on the Cameo and all that
jazz uh
that's it that's really all I got we
should probably get into this is there
anything else I need to say no let's get
into it let's get into the legendary I
love this guy I really do love him
um I'm gonna go on his talking podcast
he's got a he's starting a podcast about
eating
you know foods and so he wants me to be
on the show so nice let's get inside of
Chris Sarandon it's my point of view
of you listening to inside of you
Michael
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience hey Chris I'm good how are you
doing I'm doing great doing great just
had a birthday which was uh a seminal
one thank you by the way for your
birthday greeting and
um uh it was both shocking on the one
hand and also very kind of freeing and
revelatory in a lot of ways really I
mean I can't I look at you I never look
at you and see 80 years old this is just
there's just no way what can I tell you
I I just I just turned 50 and I'm I'm
freaking out I think I'm having a
midlife crisis did you have a midlife
crisis when you turned 50 I oddly enough
I I along the way on those you know
those uh uh kind of what signpost
birthdays of 30 40 50 60. it didn't
really hit me this one really hit me it
did yeah so major major
well because you know you you you think
just as you said to to me you don't look
80 well that's the juxtaposition of how
you look and feel to a certain extent
and also what your chronological age is
to the to the world is I mean this is a
like a major uh oh he's on his way out
kind of really that's how you feel
because you I mean people don't feel
that way I'm saying that's the way the
world sees it and so you you know you
can't help but but uh uh pick up on
the the cultural attachments of certain
certain ages right so you're telling me
you don't feel 80.
no whatever 80 supposed to feel like I
don't no how do you feel
I I feel
um I have what what my what my wife
wonderfully calls the you know I I play
the organ recital with my friends who
are my age or younger a little younger
uh the organ recital being oh yeah you
know that I I've got that my I had
herniations in my disc and uh let's see
I have a hip replacement you know you
can go on and on when you get to be a
certain age where you've had so many
things happen
uh in your life but you've also had so
many wonderful things incredible things
happen uh along the way right I mean
you've had I mean I look and how many
people could say they've been in so many
big movies
that everyone knows like you know I I
know you know that I'm the biggest
Fright Night fan yeah like The Princess
Bride and Child's Play and Nightmare
Before Christmas and Dog Day Afternoon
and like it goes on and on and uh it's
Gotta it's cool to have such a legacy to
have you know to have so much work that
you've done that so many people out
there have appreciated and love you for
I'm really proud of it and at the same
time it I I'm I'm
sometimes aghast and and kind of whoa
wait a minute this happened to me I
almost I mean I remember it I remember
it happening right but but the um the
the cultural the waves that go out in
the culture from particular pieces of
work uh it's astonishing to me just how
much uh just how much resonance they
have with people yeah I met you at a
convention one of these comic-cons yes
you and I met at a convention yeah and
uh I was just I first of all I was just
so amazed by how you know because when
you watch you know when I watch you in
all these roles I'm like God he's so
Charming I wonder how he is in real life
and you were incredibly charming and so
easy to talk to and laid back it's like
you know you don't seem affected have
you always been like that or you ever
were you ever A pompous Chris Sarandon
uh at one point actually I think I was
uh this happened I think after the I was
nominated for an Academy Award for Dog
Day Afternoon yes and then I was offered
a lot of movies I turned down a bunch of
movies but I did a few uh and I was
doing TV I was doing like Hallmark Hall
of Fame stuff and I was doing uh I
played Jesus for God's sake yeah and and
I also played Sydney Carton and Charles
darnay and The Tale of Two Cities and I
was really [ __ ] full of myself and
and I got a script called Fright Night
write an offer to do this movie and and
I said to myself as I picked up and
looked at the the title of it uh on the
cover page oh I I can't do a movie
called fright night I'm a terribly
important actor right and so and so uh
but but you know these people they they
offered me the role and you offer you
you owe them the courtesy of reading it
and I started reading it and within like
five minutes I was completely sucked in
and by the time I finished the script I
said I have to do this I got to meet
these people and it it it taught me a
lesson uh which is you know the old
bromide don't love judge a book by its
cover don't let judge a screenplay by
its title right uh and and also
um art comes in many forms
and I've always considered that when I
first started I first started in the
theater yes and I've continued to do
theater throughout my career and that
keeps you grounded
uh because you are in a a medium that
forces you to collaborate with people in
a totally different way than it does in
the movies than television as you know
you know in television and movies very
often you are part of the machine
yes and the Machine is inexorable it
just moves with you or without you
uh whereas in the theater you are really
integral to the the the performance of
this particular moment in time and you
do it live
which is an astonishing thing to stand
before an audience and and be somebody
else and have that kind of level of
communication and this is sort of a
long-winded answer I love it please keep
them long-winded
but but I I from the very beginning uh
when I graduated from
um theater school if you want to call it
that I got a master's degree in in
theater uh a performing degree and from
the time I graduated all I wanted to do
was to be have a career
and I've had a career yeah so I I I and
along the way different [ __ ] happens you
know you you do a play you you go on
tour you travel or you or you're at home
for a long time
I have a a story that I tell all the
time about uh one of my children who was
at the time I think she was like five or
six and she and a friend were having a
pizza or an ice cream or something with
the the friend's mom
and um and they were talking about what
their daddies did
and and the uh the woman taught went
talked to her daughter she said you know
what Daddy does don't you and her
daughter says yeah he makes wires in
houses that's this woman says that's
right he's an electrician and she turned
to my daughter and she said you know
what your daddy does don't you and my
daughter Alexis said yeah he looks for
work
foreign
well that's the that's the experience of
being an experience yes and that also
keeps you humble right uh and the fact
that you have to audition for people and
that you're rejected constantly no
matter what level you're at
you know you read stories all the time
I'm sure about famous actors who had to
fight for a role and didn't get it right
at the height of their fate yeah
so you know you can't take it too
terribly seriously if you do you're you
won't have a very good time being an
actor were you a popular kid in high
school growing up were you always the
good-looking athlete or did you get in
the theater in high school well and yeah
and I also want to know like what your
upbringing was but how are your parents
because they worked in restaurants right
my dad and his brother but my dad
started it owned a restaurant in a in a
coal mining town in West Virginia
uh called Beckley West Virginia
and so I grew up
playing a role
in a way because I was the son of Greek
image I was the first generation
uh uh American in fact when my parents
would take me places where they would
get together with other Greeks because
there were no Greeks in my hometown they
would parade me up to people and say
okay tell them what you are and I would
say I'm 100 American and full-blooded
Greek
and that was the dichotomy of my growing
up in this town and that is that my
parents spoke Greek at home
we ate Greek we lived that way
um all my relatives were Greek but when
I went to school I was somebody I was I
had to be somebody else
and so it to to the answer to the
question is I was popular but I was
popular because I set out to be popular
because I knew that if I didn't that I
would be
perhaps at least this was in my
imagination that I'd be ostracized and
so on because I was different
so so I played that role for a long time
and in fact all the way through college
oh not all the way but like halfway
through college I was I was in politics
at my University at Western University I
was on you know I was the the uh the
coordinator of homecoming weekend I was
in the sophomore uh honorary because I
made good grades I was uh I I was a
coordinator of leadership conference I
was going to be the student body
president so you were confident you had
a lot of confidence well under that
confident that under that patina of
confidence was insecurity
of I'll be discovered if I don't keep
playing this role and it wasn't until I
first appeared on a stage in a in a with
a you know a sizable audience that I
went oh
I hear I can pretend and it's accepted
and I don't have to I don't have to make
excuses for it to myself right
you know what I mean yeah
inside he was brought to you by Helix if
you've had eight back surgeries or any
back surgeries or your back just hurts
you might want to listen to this ad I
have gone through the ringer Ryan with
massage chairs and mattresses and
devices and really the most important
thing is sleep it's it's your bed it's
what you do I don't know what percentage
of your life but a large percentage of
your life you spend sleeping hopefully
you're not awake throughout the night
but uh until I found Helix I was I was
struggling a little bit I was waking up
in the middle of the night I was you
know not I couldn't get comfortable and
I went through a lot of mattresses uh
I've I've talked about mattresses before
and you know some are good some are fine
but these guys really know how to make a
mattress so what I like about them Helix
is that they you take a quiz they want
to get to know how you are so they could
uh
tell you what's what beds right for you
Helix sleep has a quiz it takes two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with Helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep everybody's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress bottles to choose
from they have soft medium that's for me
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers yeah I took the quiz and I'm a
medium I'm not you know I've said it
before but like the porridge you know
right in the middle is just right for me
I don't want something too hard because
then you know when you're too soft uh
it's been awesome getting messages from
you guys telling me what you think of
Helix sleep and how much it's helping
you so I appreciate that it's nice to
see look if you're looking for a
mattress just take this quiz order the
mattress that's matched to you and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again thank the
Lord Helix is awesome but you don't need
to take my word for it Helix was awarded
the number one best overall mad mattress
pick of 2020 by GQ and Wired Magazine
just go to Helix h-e-l-i-x Helix
sleep.com slash inside take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10-year warranty so if you don't
like it you try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't like it but you will
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com slash
inside that's Helix sleep.com slash
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows inside of you is brought to you
by Magic spoon I think this is the kind
of product that people have been waiting
for I've talked about this ad nauseam I
learned that big word in college
um but I think most adults miss those
days where they could just eat cereal
you don't see a lot of adults eating
cereal anymore and I think it's because
they're not as good as they were and or
if they're eating the same cereals they
were when they're older their
cholesterol Sky High it's bad for their
heart it's very sugary it's just not
good for them so what do we do once we
get to a certain age we go oh that's not
good
you know and that's a shame it's like me
it's like I'll just stop going on roller
coasters because I'm older uh the hell
with that man
magic spoon is the cereal for you if
you're an adult or anyone craving cereal
that you don't want something that's too
sugary or unhealthy cereal that's good
for you doesn't have to suck it just
needs a little magic it's time to try
magic spoon cereal the cereal that
tastes good and is good for you magic
spoon is replicated your favorite
childhood cereals to taste good and be
good for you each serving contains zero
grams of sugar over 13 grams of protein
and less than 5 grams of net carbs Ryan
wow it's a low carb keto friendly
gluten-free grain free and soy free way
to relive those moments for watching
your favorite cartoons plus it's only
140 calories a serving it's like there's
magic in every Spoonful with over eight
unique flavors you're not going to get
bored of feeling good with magic spoon
you know my favorite has to be you know
peanut butter I like the cocoa I like
the frosting I can't say the names of
the cereals that I think of back then
but this is delicious but they have so
many flavors cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry muffin Maple waffle
honey nut cookies and cream cinnamon
roll
it's just extraordinary head to
magicspoon.com IOU grab a custom bundle
of cereal and try the magic for yourself
and be sure to use our promo code IOU at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and Magic spoon is so confident
Ryan in their product it's backed with
100 happiness guarantee what cereal does
that
if you don't like it for any reason Ryan
they'll refund the money wow no
questions asked who does that
people who are confident in their
product yep remember get your next
delicious ball of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com IOU and use the code IOU
to save five dollars off and thank you
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
did you uh did you deal with any anxiety
growing up being that you felt like you
had to cover up like it was false
bravado I have to prove that I'm
somebody else absolutely all the time
that was my constant uh um struggle when
I was growing up plus plus there was uh
there was friction at home my dad was an
old-fashioned Greek and my mom was a
very Lively much younger bride and uh he
was he constantly he he was
psychologically abusive and she had lots
of uh um psychosomatic problems because
of it and um my it's a complicated story
I I'm actually writing a memoir and I'll
get into that more oh wow perhaps if
anybody listening yeah someday they'll
see but it but but yeah I was um
I think that's one of the reasons why I
ultimately became an actor I think me
too I think that there was so much I
talked about this recently but yeah the
chaos that was going on in my house it
just did I I wanted I actually became
I would stay at my friend's house and
their parents would sort of be my
parents I would spend weeks there or
nights there and I just didn't really
want to be home all the time and it was
just kind of it was kind of crazy and I
didn't think it really affected me as a
child but when you get older you start
to have certain issues and things start
to come out and you realize wow I was
anxious I was I was living in a you know
I was I was under a lot of stress and I
didn't realize it and that's how you
felt yeah and I didn't realize it either
until later how much later
uh the first time I went into therapy
when was that
oh gosh that was when my first marriage
was breaking up
and I was I was completely kind of
gobsmacked by it and didn't you know
totally unexpected I didn't understand
what was going on and so I needed to
talk to somebody and I I went to see if
there's actually a terrific therapist uh
and a lot of this stuff started to kind
of bubble to the surface
uh and um and that's when I started
talking about it and I'm still talking
about it I'm talking about it with you
yeah right now it's freeing isn't it
when you start to let these things out
or start to understand what may have
caused these issues or the cause a
certain way you act and act out and say
things and like why am I doing this and
I'm oh I'm wow I sound like my father I
sound like you know you're a product of
your own environment so having a deal
it's also very tough I'm sure uh it was
pretty emotional for you
well tremendously uh uh but out of
Crisis comes
um understanding
and uh
a certain kind of
what a piece with whatever it was that
happened that was the Catalyst for the
crisis you know uh and uh if you haven't
been through it then if you haven't been
through any crises in your life first of
all I don't know anybody who hasn't yeah
I don't know anyone yeah uh so so we're
all
kind of brothers and sisters in that
regard that we all have that in common
and Humanity does right some of us
recognize that some of us don't but I I
think one of the things about
being an actor is that it
it says to people look
this is do you see something of yourself
in this situation or in this character
uh and that's the great gift that we're
able to to share with people
yeah I feel like a lot of my things the
things that came out were ego a lot of
ego things I was upset by things because
maybe they didn't go my way or I wasn't
in control
um yeah you talked about your first
marriage was that something that wasn't
your choice that you didn't want to
divorce uh at the time no but but in
retrospect it was the best thing that
could have happened for me at that time
uh because it made me
look at some things that I'd never
looked at before that I'd taken for
granted right you know ways that I uh
dealt with uh other people with women uh
in particular which kind of mirrored my
relationship with my mom if you get into
the kind of the therapeutic part of it
right
um so uh it was revelatory I didn't
necessarily completely learn my lesson
the first time yeah
I had to get married again right and uh
and and ended up
happily for a time and also having
children which was really important to
me and I have three kids now and I have
nine grandchildren wow uh my children
are grown up and I have you know this
hassle of grandchildren that are just
the Delight of my life uh and then that
marriage ended in a kind of a crisis
situation that was actually the Catalyst
was financial trouble ah that on that
tongue and uh and now I'm married for uh
well married for more than 25 years but
together with Mike my wife Joanna for
over 30 years where you got the 30 years
that's amazing and we live we have a
wonderful life we have these
grandchildren so it all of that if if it
had my first marriage hadn't ended
this this life that I'm living now
wouldn't have existed isn't that
something so when something bad happens
you have to know that you're going to
learn from it and hopefully something
good from it that's meant to be if you
believe in all that is going to happen
yeah and then your first wife was Susan
Sarandon obviously correct and I didn't
know that until I read about it yeah I
mean and she took your name right
she did yeah well she still she still
owes me
do you guys even talk or was it was it
we haven't we haven't talked in a long
time uh although we do stay in touch uh
uh occasionally because I've had a very
strong relationship she's one of a
number of children she's the oldest of
eight or nine I can't remember now how
many but I I had a relationship with all
of her siblings when I was she and I
were married and so uh I and her parents
whom I knew well uh and actually her mom
ended up being a friend of my mom's post
this is like you know maybe 15 years ago
um because they lived in the same town
and they ended up connecting but
um uh no we we don't we're not in sort
of constant touch I think one of the
reasons probably is we didn't have
children together right whereas whereas
my uh ex Lisa and I have three kids
together and we're still you know they
we have Thanksgiving together watch your
husband come down with their kids
because they've had a couple of kids
since uh Lisa and I divorced and we all
got together and we hang out and she and
my Joanna are good friends that's that
you don't hear that very often it sounds
to me like even with the first marriage
with Susan it sounds like there's really
no ill will you've let no bygones you've
sort of that's that's rare usually I
hear horror stories in Hollywood that
they hate each other they don't talk I
could tell you about my parents haven't
talked in over 20 years they wouldn't
want to see each other it's not fun no
it was very very amicable we in fact
Susan and I used the same lawyer for our
divorce really we just we went to one
person as a kind of arbitrator and he
kind of worked things out for us
financially and uh and it posts the the
separation she went to the Oscars with
me when I was nominated what she was my
date
yeah that's that's remarkable yeah it
was very she she was great she said she
was great she's a remarkable woman yeah
that's pretty special I mean were you
one of those actors who once you started
doing theater and you hear this a lot
where
that's all I want to do I'm a theater
actor I'm an actor I don't want to do
movies I don't or were you always sort
of thinking ahead of the game like hey
hopefully this leads me to what was your
dream what were you I think the latter I
think that there was a a hope that I'd
have a career in all the mediums
particularly in in movies because I've
been a movie lover since I was young
and have only become more so as I've
gotten older and I am I have a
veneration
a a kind of worship for the history of
film and and uh or or as it was called
at the time when I'm the biggest fan of
the 30s 40s 50s but mostly you know that
golden age of the 30s and 40s right uh
of motion pictures
now a word from our sponsor better help
better help I don't know what we'd do
without better help uh you know I have
been lately dealing with a lot of
anxiety and what happens is I hyper
focus on all these negative things Ryan
that keep spiraling and I can't I can't
it's hard to focus it's and it exhausts
me and gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and I
know it's not I shouldn't be thinking
all these things and I it's like in my
mind I can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and
um
you know it could be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and I know
that therapy helps that talking to
someone and having them talk to you
objectively about what works train
professionals helps it just does I doing
it on my own isn't working it's just not
working
if I don't have someone to talk to I
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out that's how I feel
do you feel that way yeah
um you have to talk to somebody you know
people always say well how did you get
into therapy it's because I just
couldn't solve these problems on my own
I couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up until it becomes very
toxic and our body feels it
physiologically we feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why I got into therapy and
I'll tell you A lot of times I have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am I here what am
I doing and by the end of it I'm like
thank God I'm talking to somebody my
Lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option Ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists any time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read to me this is the easiest read
ever because it's just something I could
talk about forever and
um look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside you is
brought to you by Geico Geico asks how
would you love a chance to save some
money on insurance well of course you
would after all who doesn't love a great
deal right and when it comes to Great
rates on insurance for all the things in
your life Geico can help like with
insurance for your car truck motorcycle
boat and RV even help with homeowners
condo or renters coverage you could save
even more with a special discount when
you bundle your coverages Plus add the
easy to use Geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to Geico becomes an
Easy Choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
who are your influences who were who are
the actors that you admired that you
wanted and I don't know if emulates the
right word but sort of like wanted to
say I want to be someone like that uh
when I first started it was Olivier it
was Lawrence Olivier who was a theater
actor but who worked in films and and
who was a character actor even though he
was a leading man and I knew that I
didn't look like a character actor but I
felt like one because I had
a facility with you know with with
accents I had a great ear so I'm really
good with accents I have a facility of
of observation and and of of curiosity
uh and I've always thought of myself as
a character actor never as a leading man
what accents can you do but I know you
could do the English accent really well
but like what other ones can you can you
easily just jump into well I I can do
lots of accents of people who don't
speak English as a as a first language
you know I have a great Italian accent
because I was in a play where I had to
be an Italian
um aberdasher
a Man Who Sold the great wonderful
clothes all right it's amazing oh so
obviously I do a very I can do my father
let's do the father we got to hear the
father my father my father was he had
very strong Greek aklin
and he was a he was very he was a quiet
man my father
uh that is can you do Scottish
oh that's one that I I um I I won't even
attempt because it's it's not very good
it's not good but wow I used to do a
great North country accent because I did
a play in England but I did a North
Country play when I was much younger uh
I don't remember it terribly well so I
I'm not going to embarrass myself here
but
um I I just always you know of course
New York you gotta you gotta have that
one you know in your pocket yeah in
Chicago
I I played a cop a Chicago cop you just
you still got it I mean it's like wow
but that to me that was what was you
know was attractive about Olivia is
because he changed he was a chameleon uh
as I got older I started appreciating
more the people who were uh who worked a
little more organically
than Olivia did who who was he always
said it was he had to create the outside
and then the inside came right uh I I
started learning that the inside is more
important and uh the outside you can
always you know you can always paint
with colors on the outside but the
inside has to come from some experience
right what about is when you're first
transitioning from theater to TV didn't
you do a a soap opera for a while oh
yeah that was my first job when I got to
New York I got a soap opera almost right
away I mean it was unheard of you
auditioned and immediately got it I got
it but of course I was I played I played
the guy who was scrubbing in the in the
pre-op as the lead actors came through
on their way to the operating room and
basically my line was good morning
doctor
did you become a regular
uh no I was a par I was basically I was
like a you know I was I was um I was
guaranteed an episode and a half a week
for 275 dollars an episode so I made
like 350 bucks a week which paid my rent
wow and my rent was only two 250 or
something like that in a one bedroom
apartment in New York if you can believe
it uh and uh and then I got a Broadway
show of the Rothschilds
and you know I was in that for almost a
year and then I started doing theater
again uh and then I got I was replacing
somebody else in a place where I was
Julia in a Broadway musical wow I'd
never done a musical before so you were
getting a lot of attention in the
Broadway scene they were your name was I
guess I was starting to anyway yeah yeah
yeah and then and then dog day happened
how did Dog Day happen I mean did you
obviously auditioned for it yeah oh yeah
did you who'd you audition for Sydney
lomat the director and uh and Al Pacino
and the producers Marty alfond and uh
Marty bregman Marty bregman was Al's yes
manager I think at the time were you
nervous in the room
well you know it's such a cool character
who's kind of like the nerves get to him
anyway in a way well actually it's
interesting because it I don't know
about you I I and you tell me when you
read something that really fits and you
understand it and you know what you're
doing then the nerves are there but it's
not about oh my God I'm gonna [ __ ] this
up it's more about
oh man I I have to ride this right I
have to ride this at the moment I have
to feel that I have to really get into
this right now and the nerves help
yeah they don't help when you're when
you're unsure now do you do anything to
prepare before you go into a room when
you're about to go into a room is there
something you do any kind of practice
that you have any breathing or do you
just go you don't think about it if uh
if I'm prepared I'd basically just go
uh yeah it doesn't really I I don't
think it necessarily I mean you know I I
got advice one time a long time ago when
I was a young actor of just think of
them when you walk in the room think of
them sitting on a toilet
everybody you're auditioning for that's
the common denominator we all have to
take a dump at some point in our lives
right yes and they're not you know there
there's nothing extra special about
these people but for the dog they
audition it was really interesting
because first of all this was it was a
great script yeah uh it won an Academy
Award it was nominated for eight Academy
Awards I think and had won for best
screenplay Frank Pearson right right and
uh and I immediately understood this
character
and I I think part of that was
understanding the otherness
of somebody who is a his body is foreign
to him yeah and in my case my psyche was
kind of foreign I was you know I was
this Greek America of 100 American
full-blooded Greek and so I understood
uh uh Leon shermers the name of the guy
in the movie yeah and I I just got it
and and so I went in very prepared did
you read without did you read what they
read without yeah yeah we read the
telephone scene right the telephone I
loved that scene because you're like
you're holding your buttons on your
shirt or something you're like that
comes from a I stole that from a
photograph of the guy coming being led
out of the police car and his clutching
his robe around him to to maintain his
privacy you know yeah I just thought it
was like a nervous cool little tip that
you were doing I stole it I stole it
did you when you let me ask you when you
finish this audition and you're you just
read without did you get any sort of
affirmation or any kind of like
I it was obvious that it was going well
and Sydney Lamont came over to me and he
gave me the best note I think probably
I've ever gotten from a director what
was it he said because I was playing it
very sort of Blanche Dubois
right right and Sydney said a little
less Blanche Dubois a little more
Queen's housewife when you come back wow
and that was the note that went oh oh oh
okay all right now I know how to locate
this guy
and also that he's not this this what
this um elevated
Queen he was a queen's housewife
wow and you just didn't you knew exactly
what he wanted so the next time I came
in I read with Alan I did you know I was
it was I was talking you know
wow that is so cool I could just yeah I
could just see the room I mean did you
know after that this the next time you
read was there something that made you
go I got this [ __ ] thing yeah yeah
what was it
but just that you know there was a real
sort of palpable sense of of everybody
being genuinely
uh we really liked that that was great
and you don't often have that in an
audition because people always play it
so cool yeah but you let it all out
there you're like this is the role this
is the part and I think there's
something to be said about
um when you audition and you get the
part you know that that's what they want
but when you get an offer for a movie
and I've had some you know a few offers
here and there tv offers yeah yeah but
you get there and you're like uh what
what part of me do they want here I you
know you're unsure of yourself and then
if they don't want it it's it's almost
like an audition believe it or not even
though I hate auditioning is better how
do you feel about that I I don't know
that auditioning is necessarily better
well yeah maybe if if the circumstances
are like the one that I just described
but you don't often have that kind of
experience I I mean you know especially
early in my career when I go into
auditions I I I felt you know totally
disoriented I didn't know what the hell
was going on uh and after a while you
know you kind of get the feel for what
it's like to go in a room and and
impress people quote-unquote impress uh
and the best way to do that is to be
prepared and to to know the character
right and the always the the most
disastrous auditions are the ones where
I don't know who this person is yeah or
you don't know the material or you don't
know the material of yeah or I I don't
really have a line into who this person
is this was your this was your first
audition for a film at this point or no
no was this the first role you got first
film uh it was the first role I got I
don't remember I probably auditioned for
things before that uh I don't remember
quite frankly it's been so long yeah but
uh but this was the first definitely the
first big role I got a big role not
really a big role
were you surprised when you got
nominated for an Academy Award for it
I was
I was grateful I wasn't totally
surprised because I was getting a lot of
positive feedback when the movie came
out that it was a you know that it had
an impact
right particularly this is the phone
scene right uh with with Al and a lot of
that oddly enough uh despite the fact
that it was a great script
uh a lot of that scene was improvised
around the original writing of the scene
that is that Al and I Sydney lament
always rehearses or rehearsed his movies
and this one dog day rehearsed for like
two or three weeks wow like a like a
play you know there were the the
furniture was taped out on the floor
there were you know props uh and uh Al
and I were sitting and reading the phone
scene the first time and we were reading
it through together and we both have the
same reaction which was
uh my wife was a wonderful amazing
acting teacher she calls uh
putting a uh putting a hat on a hat
when something's already there when the
situation is melodramatic
you don't need to play melodrama the
writing doesn't have to be melodramatic
the situation takes care of that right
and and in the original writing of that
scene it was high drama immediately
calling each other names pissed off
because their relationship in real life
these two guys was highly volatile all
right you know I mean crazy [ __ ] yeah
that went on between these guys right
and the ultimately got married in a
church wedding and and Leon was you know
full bride regalia I have a photo of
that by the way which is quite I have a
story about that too oh you might
understand that you might have to send
that all right
and so we both thought you don't have to
start the scene at at uh Defcon one
the scene should start with you know two
people haven't seen each other a while
in a while and what's going on how you
doing basically
I don't know I'm you know and then you
start kind of because they've known each
other for years it's not like this is a
new uh event for them speaking on the
phone but then the melodrama
sort of evolves in the scene and Alan
and I started riffing on what it might
be like if we started it differently and
Sydney said wait wait wait wait wait and
he got somebody with a tape recorder and
so we recorded one with the information
that was in Frank Pearson scene but we
kind of redid it just reshuffled it a
bit right and when we finished Cindy
said okay here this is missing we need
this information so and so and then we
did another improv and they recorded
that one and then we did it like maybe
two or three more and then all of us got
together
as I recall in Marty bregman's office
one evening
and we looked through all the scripts
and we collated them into one and that's
the scene that's in the movie
wow that never happens rarely happens
never never
are you to this day uh when's the last
time you talked to Al Pacino
I run into him occasionally I last time
I saw him I think I was leaving a a
restaurant and I think he was arriving
and we stood and chatted for a few
minutes and uh in fact I uh I wrote him
a letter recently about three or four
months ago uh asked him to do my podcast
and uh he demured because he was very
busy but he wrote me a nice note back
and you know we kind of exchanged uh uh
information more than anything do you do
you keep in touch with any actors from
any of the movies that you've done like
oh really keep in touch you do you
become friends with a lot of people it
depends on the the circumstances of the
movie I mean I'm sure you've had this
experience too where the experience
isn't great then you'd probably end up
staying away from those people have you
had those where you don't like working
with someone
uh yeah
yeah and how do you deal and I won't
speak ill of the dead that's all I'll
say right but you just uh it wasn't a
good experience oh God they put you
through hell oh Jesus uh but uh the
Fright Night people all we're all still
friends you know I I'm in touch with
them you know maybe a couple of times a
month John Stark and Tom Holland and and
Amanda Burse and Bill Ragsdale uh but
you know whatever we do a convention
where the movie is featured we get
together and we sit and we talk and we
eat and we laugh
a lot yeah laugh a lot
um uh Carey Ellis and I stay in touch
from Princess Bride wow well very much
every once in a while I'll I'll share a
text with Rob Reiner
um but Carrie and I are very close
friends did you have any idea I mean I
know you like the script and it drew you
to you know
take the part uh in Fright Night as
Jerry Dandridge but did you did you
while you were filming did you say
there's something special here there's
something different here I thought so
absolutely
script was great and also Tom knew
exactly how he wanted to shoot the movie
he described it to me when we first met
he he went through it's literally scene
by scene shot by shot he described that
I love Tom Holland I love that man I
played tennis yeah he's into his house
he's a he's a he's an extraordinary guy
well he obviously loved you because he
brought you in the child's play as well
yeah yeah he fought time thought for me
on that movie really the studio yeah the
studio didn't want me in in the
producers and Tom basically said I if
I'm going to do this movie and I'm going
to do it with him yeah I think you know
you have this knack for
you you play some of these characters
that are you know evil or dark but you
bring something to it that makes them so
likable which is very difficult to do
but it's also it makes the characters
more likable and and the believability
when you're doing fright night that's
one of the things that I loved is all
the actors really committed and it
wasn't this farce yeah it was like you
had Roddy McDowell and everybody took
their part and ran with it and you
played this villainous character and yet
you were so likable and charismatic and
is that something that they just offered
you the role right
yes yeah did you did you come up with
all these things or did Tom give you
well we had a really nice collaboration
in the making of the movie and I have to
credit Tom uh tremendously for for both
accepting my ideas and also offering me
stuff that uh that made the character
particularly more seductive because that
was an important element in the
character you know the fact that you
have to believe that that these uh the
victims are willingly going to this guy
right uh and and part of that is the
fact that he has this kind of seductive
Charisma yeah uh where he's he's very
very charming and uh likable uh when you
when you meet him on a human level yeah
right uh and then there were also there
was stuff like you know the the kind of
light motif of of Jerry Dandridge eating
the fruit the Apple I yeah people to you
know I've talked about this a lot but uh
uh how do you create a background for a
character who's not human
so you have to you know you have to come
up with some some ideas and one of the
ideas I had was uh well let me check out
vampire bats and see if there's anything
there and I discovered that uh the
majority the not like something like 90
80 90 of the bats that live in in nature
are fruit bats
so I thought well what if there's a
little what if there's a little fruit
bad DNA in Jerry Dandridge
uh that he craves fruit so Tom loved the
idea and we worked it in and and out of
that came that great thing that he does
cinematically where uh uh Charlie is
sitting in the bushes spying on Jerry
and Jerry walks out of the house and
he's eating an apple
and he takes a bite out of it and he
knows Charlie's there and he throws the
Apple toward where Charlie's hiding yeah
and the apple rolls up and you see this
this grotesque bite that's come out of
the Apple that's not human
that's Tom taking my idea and turning it
into
something that's just you know a Cuda
whatever you want to call it uh well I
have the poster right here you're so
cool Brewster Tom Holland he signed my
Friday night poster it's right across me
you can't see it but lastly about Fright
Night Roddy McDowell I mean what can you
say I mean are there any special stories
you haven't told or that you remember
little moments that you're like wow this
guy's great
I just I just remember Roddy being so
accessible
and also being such a font of Hollywood
history and to me that's you know
mother's milk I love those stories the
stories about the people he worked with
and he also over the time over the years
that I got to know Roddy he included Us
in his in his life
uh and it so happened that my wife
Joanna and he did a play together on the
road so she knew him really well wow so
we would go to his house and have dinner
with you know the uh folks we never had
dinner with Elizabeth Taylor but I I
held out the possibility at some point
who's the most famous person you've had
dinner with
besides Al Pacino you've probably eaten
with Al yeah yeah I've eaten without
um
golly Sean Connor Sean Connery yeah I
did a movie with Sean in Spain
how was how is he oh he was so great
Sean uh very down to earth Scotsman uh
you know this just this assault of the
earth kind of guy who also was a very
very uh conscientious actor and would
love to run scenes and rehearse and and
and do the work you know Sean didn't
just show up he he he he knew what he
was doing so yeah he didn't just uh
depend on that amazing Sean Connery
Charisma he was also somebody who worked
hard at it what do you talk to Sean
Connery about at dinner oh everything
everyone what did he want to tell he
wanted to talk he wanted to talk about
golf
um which wasn't very interesting to me
but we talked about the theater we
talked about uh acting we talked about
movies uh we talked about
um we also had the cast of that movie
this movie called Cuba which is kind of
disappeared it was directed by Richard
Lester who directed A Hard Day's Night
and help oh wow uh and the Three
Musketeers the earlier Three Musketeers
and and Richard was a an very
interesting guy
um who uh didn't like making movies he
loved editing movies but he didn't like
making them so there was a so we talked
a lot about Richard and you know our our
difficulties with Richard who was a
Charming lovely man but not not fun in
terms of actually working did you get
yeah did you get offered uh by the way
did you get offered Princess Bride was
that an offer the no I audition you did
yeah I auditioned for Rob Rob Reiner and
uh Bill Goldman how many times William
Goldman once once yeah did you have the
English accent oh yeah yeah you poured
it on oh yeah yeah just with a you know
with a paintbrush and uh uh a uh bucket
and you know whatever I could absolutely
uh no it was actually it was a fun
audition because it was at uh William
Goldman's apartment on Central Park West
and I was on my way to the audition and
I remember I took a bus up Uptown and I
had the the New York daily news I think
it was and on the back page was the the
uh it's always the sports section I'm a
big sports fan and uh I was pissed off
because the Knicks had drafted a guy
that I thought was a disaster right
right and so I'm holding this paper and
for some reason I knew the scene I knew
it you know I knew what I was doing I
felt confident and I walked in and they
both you know Rob is such a he's just
such a mensch yeah and you know he came
up and he shook my head how you doing
nice to meet you how how how's it going
I love you I love your acting you know a
wonderful career and Bill Goldman who is
a little shy
and I I said well I said to be honest
I'm in a really kind of bad mood because
the New York Knicks just drafted Kenny
Walker and Bill golden immediately
perked up because he's a huge Knicks fan
right and he and I started talking about
this trade
well I mean this draft choice and we
talked for maybe 15 minutes we were
going on and on about the Knicks and how
they'd [ __ ] things up and they'd say
that and that and finally Rob
interrupted us and he said excuse me uh
can I can I interrupt you guys do would
you mind reading Chris of course not and
I read the scene
and after I and after I finished not
after I finished just the sort of
penultimate line in the scene
Rob started laughing hilariously and
he's a great audience as one of his you
know great talents right and uh after it
was over
I said he said that was that was perfect
that was just [ __ ] fabulous that was
just great and I realized that I played
the scene very seriously
because comedy is a serious business yes
you know yeah uh and and and the the
tone that I established in the scene was
just what he was looking for and that's
what did it so you didn't play it up at
all do you remember the scene do you
remember yeah yeah yeah it's where it's
where Humperdinck says to her I hope
you'll consider me as an alternative to
suicide because she talks about how
she's going Buttercup is gonna you know
throw herself off of parapet or
something I can't remember exactly what
her line was and and Humperdinck looks
at her very sincerely because he can
sell it this guy he knows how to sell it
and he says sincerely totally sincerely
I I hope you'll
consider me as an alternative to Suicide
you can't play that line
humorously just as you can't you know
I've got my country's 500th anniversary
to plan my my wife to murder Gilder to
Frankfurt I'm swamped you can't say you
can't do that with you know you can't
consider what's the comic timing right
right you know you have to you have to
know what humperding is after at that at
that moment in his life was there a lot
of Direction during the movie did he
have direction for you or did you for
the most part were doing your own thing
I think that one of the things that Rob
does really well is he trusts casting
she trusts his actors he believes
strongly in
casting the right people
and um
and except for a few things
I would get some direction for Rob and I
would say okay and I would try it that
way and then he'd say okay now try it
your way
and sometimes he'd take my take and
sometimes he'd take his but that's you
know that's a joy to have that kind of
Direction absolutely you know that
there's a moment at the end of the movie
where uh where Wesley says that they're
confronting each other and and you know
the audience knows that Wesley is
severely compromised right and
Humperdinck is about to to engage him in
Sword Play and he's the world's greatest
swordsman except for of course Wesley
and and indigo and uh and and
Wesley says
uh humperding says to him something like
you know I know that you're compromised
I know that you're you you're you're not
are you bluffing
and he says
um drop that sword and he sticks his
sword out and Humperdinck drops the
sword and goes and sits down right
the coward beneath the facade Right
comes out and just as a natural thing
because of the costume I took my I took
the tail of the costume and tucked it
under me as I sat down
and Rob came over to me and thought I
think that's a little over the top can
you not do that this time and we did it
the other way and then he said let's do
it again and do it your way
and that's the take he kept really yeah
and it's it's funny but it's it's
situational funny right it's not you
know again one of these movies where
you're doing it you're like this is
special again did you feel that with
this one
we knew that the this was a great script
we all love the script I read the book
like 20 years before and I just flipped
over the book and we all knew that it
was a great script the casting was just
uh you know out of this world uh
and Rob's take on it was obviously the
ripe exactly the right tone all the way
through you don't it's and it's the same
I mean it's actually similar in in uh
Fright Night in that you you have fun
with the genre but you don't make fun of
it right you don't look at the audience
in wink and say we're we're having fun
with this aren't we folks you play it
totally straight right that will kill it
the other way will kill it yeah and so
we knew that all that was in place he
had the best art director he had the
best you know the top of the line uh
British uh period costume woman Phyllis
I forgot phyllis's last name now
um the makeup people were wonderful the
the DP was like one of the one of the
top DPS in in England
um Adrian Biddle and uh
but at the same time I you know as as
William Goldman said in his great book
about Hollywood he said the quote that
everybody quotes is nobody in Hollywood
nobody knows anything
[Laughter]
yes in this case Rob knew
exactly what he had what the pro is
problematic was the marketing of the
movie because nobody knew how to how to
pigeonhole it right was it a romance was
it a comedy was it a an adventure was it
a thrill what was it and so uh when the
movie first came out the marketing was
awful right it was terrible uh and so
the movie did a sort of you know
moderate amount of business but over
time people discovered it and discovered
what the tone of the movie was and and
and it's become this multi-generational
phenomenon it's you know it's
extraordinary what happened but there's
no way to know that that's going to
happen no no way is that a character you
think that if someone asked you to
revisit it you could just jump into it
today oh absolutely you could you could
just jump into it absolutely we did it
we did you know we did the reading
we did the reading for uh Wisconsin
Democrats and we made like something
like five million bucks are you serious
yeah I gotta listen where can I listen
to that oh I'm sure it's online
somewhere The Princess Bride reading
with the the yeah with the whole cast
except for obviously Andre who had
passed away how was he
a cutie pie really yes the loveliest guy
and also the interesting smart uh uh and
prodigious in so many ways he was really
uh he was an extraordinary human being
Andre that's amazing uh when you you had
to audition for Jack Skellington The
Nightmare Before Christmas right you
auditioned for that yeah I mean talk
about a role that a gift that keeps on
giving oh
boy I mean there's the here's the lock
in my life yeah exactly and that was the
you didn't you just auditioned you
obviously Tim Burton just heard your
voice you didn't meet him right yes and
they they had already done Danny elpin's
songs so they knew what kind of voice
they were looking for for the speaking
part of uh Jack sellington and I guess
you know again Serendipity that I had a
vocal Timbre that that matched Danny's
singing and uh that's it do you do
anything with your voice could you jump
into it do you have a line you could say
Eureka
Eureka hello it's Jack
did you have to read twice or one
audition like this is a guy
I just read once and what was Tim Burton
like
uh Tim uh I think people who know the
movie know he didn't direct it that uh
Henry Selleck directed it wonderful stop
action stop-motion action uh animated
director and then I got together with
Tim after uh for ADR uh for uh looping
uh because he was not satisfied with
some of the line readings and I was not
satisfied with some of my own work and
so I took some notes and I went in and
Tim was very open about you know you
want to make a change here you want to
try this you want to try that uh he was
great he was really and still is I mean
whenever I see him he's you know open
arms and uh he's a lovely guy so you're
80 years old you don't feel 80. it's
just you have to keep your mind I have
to keep reminding you but what what what
else do you think you want to do is are
you someone who are like I've done
enough which obviously anybody looks at
your body works gone he's done enough he
can do whatever he wants now or do you
still love to work do you still love do
doing it
I don't love acting as I I shouldn't say
I don't love acting I don't love what
goes into it as much as I used to
because it's exhausting yeah it's it's a
it's a it's a hard job
uh I'm not complaining because all those
years I've done it I've enjoyed every
moment with the exception of one one
movie one movie which you can't say
huh which you can't say no well I can
say sure the Sentinel that's one move
you didn't like from the beginning until
the end what was about that the director
really Michael winter who was a not a I
mean again the speaking ill of the dead
but I spoke ill of him when he was alive
he just didn't like him you didn't get
along he was a he was a
a dick he was a dick yeah I mean he he
he did things on that film that were
unforgivable with members of the of of
the uh some of the extras uh and some of
the things he would say he was a
negative human being uh he was um I I
like it was one of those movies where
you're like wow I he's making me hate
acting for this movie I literally I I
literally quit for a while
I I literally I didn't know what to do I
was so disillusioned uh I ended up going
to Africa uh I said I'm getting out of
the country I got I gotta completely
wash my system of this uh and hopefully
I'll feel refreshed when I come back and
uh I ultimately I did but boy I was I I
almost
and I and the reason just because I did
it for all the wrong reasons
I did it for money I did it for uh the
fact that I was becoming a movie star
and a leading man and uh uh
I thought well this is the next step I'm
going to become even a bigger movie star
and so I did it for all the wrong
reasons it had nothing to do with the
work it had nothing to do with the
material
uh and so I learned my lesson
never did it again how long did it take
to you before you got back to acting oh
God six months at least I was gone I I
you know it took me a week or two to to
figure out how to get out of the country
and where to go I talked to some people
who have been to Africa and I I went to
Kenya and Tanzania by myself and I drove
around for two weeks just driving
through you know game reserves and what
year was this
oh God I have to look it up were you
were you married at the time uh no you
weren't so that's why you had the
freedom because I was separated yeah
yeah I was I was but then by then I had
separated Susan and I had separated
right man but you learned a lot from it
I mean yeah absolutely you know if it
hadn't been for that movie I I'd have
kept going on that path right and uh
would have been a very unhappy guy
ultimately
this is called [ __ ] talking with Chris
Sarandon this is these are my top tier
patrons this is rapid fire if you want
to become a patron you get to ask some
questions go to patreon.com inside of
you I love you I'll email you back
they're great they're amazing and uh
they have some questions so you could
this is rapid fire if you want if you
feel like elaborating you certainly can
yeah
um Michelle K you've sort of talked
about this a little bit but maybe
there's a story you could share any fun
behind the scenes stories you can share
on the filming of Princess Bride or at
least one uh walking through the halls
of a of a an old uh medieval castle that
we shot in called Haddon Hall
and as I'm heading toward uh shooting a
scene suddenly I hear Rob Reiner Chris
guest and Mandy Patinkin singing doo-wop
doo-wop doo-wop did you sing with them
uh sadly no no I have one of the regrets
only regret I have from that shoot uh we
already asked this Emily I said you have
any good memories from working on the
set with Andre the Giant you already
mentioned that I mean yeah Andre was
actually I never worked specifically but
I got to be around him a lot and he was
just yeah he was a fabulous guy in fact
I do have a great story about Andre say
it
uh my daughters at the time were uh
three and a half and two
and I'm heading to England and I had to
be on location so they didn't come with
me in the beginning because we were in a
hotel uh up in the you know Derbyshire
somewhere and uh and so I said okay I'm
going to I'm going to England and uh I
I'm gonna be and there's a princess in
the movie and I'm assuming they're gonna
go oh really and nothing
and and then uh there's a sword fight
and then there's a giant and as soon as
like the word giant got out of my lips
both of my girls perked up and they
started throwing peppering me with a
question what's the giant like Daddy how
big is he he's as big as a house as big
as a car is he really really big could
he pick you up and squash it maybe you
know just kids right so every time now
I'm on location every time I talk to
them they're as soon as I'd say hi
kitties hi baby how are you Daddy loves
you he misses you hi daddy where's the
giant is he as big as a house as big as
a car same thing right so finally they
come to England
and I realize they have to meet Andre
so I go to Andre and I say can the kids
are yeah sure boss so we so one day he's
working when I'm not working the scene
where he rescues Mandy the indigo
from he's in the Brew he's the brute
Squad right and uh I we go to his
trailer his trailer is as big as a
boxcar because he couldn't get into the
makeup trailer
and he's sitting down at the end right
and I'm holding one of my kids and my
ex-wife is holding the other and we walk
up the steps and turn the corner and we
look down the length of the the makeup
trailer and Andre gets up
and suddenly the reality hits my girls
and they start screaming at the top of
their lungs
[Music]
so you know high-pitched thing that
little girls can do right can shatter
your nerves they and they wouldn't stop
and so I take them away and I go back to
apologize to Andre and I say Andre Andre
I'm so sorry and he said don't worry
boss they either run to me or they'll
run away from me
and that was his experience because he
was the most famous person in the world
almost yeah wow I would have loved to
meet but he handled it beautifully
oh that is amazing Sheila G just says
favorite memory from working A Nightmare
Before Christmas do you have any famous
favorite memories
the first time I walked into the studio
in San Francisco where we were shooting
and there were the storyboards were on
the walls and I got to look at the sets
and and watch those extraordinary
artists who who actually did the stop
motion
do you have a lot of toys do you have a
lot of Jack Skellington toys at the
house uh actually I have a uh four or
five of his the original heads jackheads
because there were 400 of them
wow and I have the chalkboard which is
I'm looking at it now in my office it's
over at the other side of the room uh
that Jack writes on when he's trying to
figure out the formula for Christmas
right
yeah do you do you keep anything else
from other sets anything else uh I used
to keep Flags I have Prince humperding's
flag uh I played a blanket a couple of
times on PBS I have a couple of uh old
Union flags from that time
um I can't remember the other ones I had
but I used to keep stuff like that but I
don't I don't have a lot of stuff no
right so wait did you say you wanted to
start you're starting a podcast yeah
yeah well what's it called You Know
What's it gonna be it's called cooking
by heart I grew up in a restaurant so uh
I'm talking to friends of mine and
hopefully you and I will have this
conversation at some point yeah and we
talk about how we grew up around food
what it was like around the dinner table
when you were five years old six years
old 10 12 15 whatever and the stories
that come out are extraordinary you you
wouldn't believe some of the stuff that
that happens in these conversations I
don't know if you'd want to talk to me
because my mom used to make a lot of
Frozen Foods that's part of what comes
out yeah exactly but also also it ends
up being about it's not just about the
food it's about the people and the
stories attached to the those times in
your life what's it going to be called
do you have any idea yet cook cooking by
heart oh cooking by heart is the title
and when is that going to be available
uh uh we're shooting for a uh an early
fall lunch amazing and where could they
go to find this I mean they I guess just
wherever you get your podcast wherever
you're yeah wherever you find your
favorite podcast I'm leaving that up to
other people and are you on social media
I am and what's your what's your
Instagram uh my Instagram is uh the the
Chris Sarandon I have to look it up look
it up you gotta follow this guy he's a
legend yeah yeah wait a minute wait a
minute oh it's the official Chris
Sarandon the official Chris yeah
follow him Carrie always follows him
many people follow him he's a delight
this has been a real joy I love hearing
stories I love hearing you know
truthfully I've seen I've loved so many
of your of of your movies and thank you
Michael I just love I love meeting you
and and getting to know you a little bit
better and I got to know you a lot more
today and I think everyone else will
this has been a real treat listen to his
new podcast it's coming out follow him
on Instagram the legendary I have a web
a website as well chrisaranda.com
chriserandon.com and uh hey I really
thank thank you for taking the time oh
please my pleasure my pleasure I'm Gonna
Keep I'm gonna keep in touch with you
whether you like it or not that's a deal
all right fine okay I'll see you later
it was just really enjoyable I wish that
he was here in person he wasn't but uh
just a wonderful guy he does not appear
to be 80 years old I couldn't believe
it's amazing how he looks I hope I look
like that I hope I'm in shape like he is
and then I saw him uh you know after we
recorded this I saw him at a con and
just gave me the biggest hug and it was
so sincere and sweet uh Chris Sarandon
folks
um yeah legend legend uh let's do it
let's do the uh the shout outs these are
the top tier patrons go to patreon.com
inside of you uh again uh these patrons
get their name shouted out at the end of
every episode some have been here since
the beginning since the Inception of
this show or since Patron Patron started
or I started doing it and uh couldn't
thank you more couldn't thank you enough
here we go Nancy D Leah s Sarah V little
Lisa you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike e l Don
Supremo 99 more Santiago M Chad
W correct Leanne P Janine R Maya P
Maddie s Belinda and Chris
Sarandon no
no h Chris H is Right Dave yep H Dave H
is Right Sheila G Brad d Ray a h yes
Tabitha Tom and Liliana hey
Talia C no M Betsy D Chad d l Marion Dan
and big Stevie W Angel uh
uh M Rhiannon C Cory
L Corey K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C
and T gavinator David C Ryan's upset
with himself John B Brandy D Camille s
Joey M Eugene and
Leah correct Nikki G Corey kdb Patricia
Heather L Megan T Mal s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Sarah s Eric H
Shane RMR Jeremy V Andrew M zaruichi 77
hi zotuichi Oracle Chris R Karina and
Michelle D Amanda R Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie k
land uh Lena 82
jorel
Billy yes you know what's nice is seeing
a lot of those names are also patrons
I'm talking for Talk phone they haven't
left me on the show nice you guys
haven't left me you've stuck with me and
uh I don't know what else to say but
thank you thank you so much for sticking
around until next time
we will see on the flip side from the
Hollywood Hills in California I am
Michael Rosenbaum I am Ryan Taz we
appreciate you a little wait for the
camera and uh as always be good to
yourself do what you have to do try to
enjoy this I was going to say get
through the day don't get through the
day enjoy the day embrace the day man uh
all right we'll talk to you next week
see you Ryan bye foreign
[Music]